la parole est à notre collègue daniel
laurent pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre ma question porte sur
la politique fiscale aussi du
gouvernement qui a provoqué depuis le
début du quinquennat
une rupture entre nos compatriotes
l'impôt et l'état je pense aux classes
moyennes qui paye comme d'habitude
depuis lourd tribut elles ont vite
compris qu'elle avait été dupé avant
d'être tondus je pense aussi aux
personnes âgées
nouvellement assujettis à l'impôt malgré
leurs petites retraites
elles ne font part de leur
incompréhension et de leur désarroi
quel est votre parade aucune réforme de
fond à cause de la seule perspective de
si dans le relèvement des seuils des
impôts financé par la hausse de la
taxation du diesel sans arrêt vous
donner l'illusion de donner d'une main
alors que vous reprenez de l'autre en
ajoutant des taxes supplémentaires au
passage monsieur le premier ministre
vous faisiez la semaine dernière un mea
culpa ce a déjà été dit sur la hausse
sans précédent des impôts pour les
ménages et des entreprises
en effet ce sont 10 milliards de plus
d'impôts que les ménages ont payé en
5 en 2015 et 0,1 environ 4 de puces en
2016 aujourd'hui presque tous les pays
en europe font leur révolution fiscale
il baisse les impôts pour relancer
l'économie ils réduisent leurs déficits
et leur chômage diminue euh je ne peux
m'empêcher d'évoquer les conséquences
dramatiques sur l'économie locale et
l'emploi de la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités avec toutes les charges
supplémentaires que vous avez ajouté
depuis 2012 alors que la pression
fiscale pour les ménages et les
entreprises atteint des records
votre gouvernement compte sur les
contribuables pour financer localement
les économies qu'il entend réaliser au
niveau national c'est un nouveau jeu de
dupes
il faut conclure ans les français sont
très inquiets pour leur avenir et celui
de leurs enfants
le pouvoir d'achat ne cesse de baisser
nos entreprises sont asphyxiés les
charges et les normes les contraignent
la reprise tant annoncée n'est pas hors
des murs s'il vous plaît demandez donc à
nos compatriotes si notre pays se
redresse
et vous verrez que vous n'êtes pas dans
le même monde quand aurez-vous monsieur
le premier ministre le courage sûrs de
ne voir mes reer et de dire la vérité
aux français quelles sont les vraies
réformes que vous comptez prendre
rapidement on réponde pour deux minutes
la parole est à jean marie le guen en
charge des relations avec cette ardeur
la parole monsieur le ministre le
sénateur visiblement vous étiez emporté
par la polémique et je le regrette par
l'outrance et je le dis d'autant plus
que je crois que nos compatriotes au
moment à la période difficile et
compliqué que nous vivons tantôt plans
économique social mais aussi au plan
politique je pensais aussi que ce
contexte vous ferait réfléchir sur la
responsabilité des propos que nous
tenons les uns et les autres
eh bien je pense que ces propos n'ont
pas à être ces questions n'ont pas être
traités de cette façon de la même façon
que en charge des relations avec le
parlement
j'espère trouver dans la haute assemblée
est effectivement aussi une approche de
ce type de problème qui se fait dans un
contexte différent des emportements
polémique que l'on peut connaître par
ailleurs alors revenons aux faits c'est
que effectivement monsieur le sénateur
vous auriez pu parce que vous parlez et
vous souhaiteriez parler de la vérité
vous auriez pu d'abord constaté que les
baisses de charges qui ont eu lieu cette
année et celles qui sont programmés dans
le projet de budget que vous allez
adopter ou en tout cas examiné la
semaine prochaine
je m'avance toujours plein d'optimisme
eh bien vous auriez pu constater parce
que ça va dans le sens de ce qui devrait
être vos préoccupations ce sont plus de
9 millions de français qui verront leur
impôt sur le revenu et quand on parle de
ces français ces neuf millions de
français se sont effectivement se sont
effectivement le coeur de nos classes
moyennes à moins que vous considériez
que ce sustt le décile supérieur qui et
les classes moyennes qui vous intéresse
alors s'agissant de la justice fiscale
nous mettons en oeuvre nos engagements
et nous le faisons en ayant le souci
effectivement des comptes publics car
les comptes publics
monsieur le sénateur vous le savez
ils ont été très largement dégradés plus
de 600 milliards
nos conclusions à vous dites non
monsieur le sénateur ces 600 millions de
dettes
ils sont votre fardeau il faudra que
vous les assumiez et que vous nous
disiez comment vous allez faire pour
assumer les promesses démagogiques que
vous faites par ailleurs merci monsieur
muscle